bonjour j'avais dit que je ferais
sûrement une pause de chroniques de prof
pendant l'été mais c'est pas vous
abandonner pendant deux mois donc j'ai
décidé de lancer un petit format qui
s'appellera les gentes dames bad ass et
qui présentera des femmes qui ont fait
des choses intéressantes au niveau
politique ou scientifique ou juste dont
j'avais envie de parler
elles ont vécu à des périodes diverses
et n'ont aucun lien entre elles si ce
n'est que ce sont des femmes
et qu'on n'en parle pas assez dans les
manuels scolaires et partout ailleurs
alors pour commencer j'ai choisi de vous
présenter baudis et à que les latins
appelle aussi boudicca on connaît sa vie
à partir de deux récits celui de tacite
et celui de duke a suisse qui sont tous
les deux des romains et qui n'ont
probablement jamais rencontré vos 10 k
alors ces récits sont à prendre avec
précaution pour planter le décor
boudicca est né vers 30 avant
jésus-christ on n'est pas sûr de la date
est morte en 61 après jésus-christ cette
fois on est sûr de la date
tu sens la fin tragique d'après dion
cassius c'était une reine du peuple dei
ceni qui vivaient dans la région du
norfolk à l'est de la bretagne nord s
à l'époque il s'agissait d'une province
romaine en effet le beau père de baudis
et a donc le père de son mari l'ancien
roi avait conclu une alliance avec le
romain pour protéger ses terres et son
peuple
le problème est qu'à la mort du mari de
bouzic à ce dernier legs la moitié du
royaume à sa femme et ses filles et
l'autre moitié à l' empire romain on ne
sait pas si c'était ce qui était prévu
par la loi ou s'il a fait ça en espérant
que les romains se montrerait un peu
plus clément avec son peuple et c'est
raté le procurateur romain en charge de
ces territoires cayuse des cyanus en
aurait profité pour augmenter les impôts
des esséniens piller les terres mêmes la
famille royale est touchée puisque
boudicca qui tentent de protester et
fouetter devant son peuple et ses deux
filles sont violées
d'après test parce que dion cassius ne
parle pas des filles encore une fois les
sources sont pas très sûr à prendre avec
précaution en réponse à ces violences
faites à l'encontre du peuple et de la
famille royale
le peuple des esséniens se révoltent
avec à sa tête boudicca on ne sait pas
si d'autres peuples les rejoigne mais en
tout cas elle arrive à rassembler une
armée d'environ 120 mille hommes
au départ une rencontre pas trop de
résistance puisque à ce moment là les
légions romaines qui sont en bretagne
sont occupés à chasser du droid sur
l'île de mona elle prend rapidement les
gilles de camilo dounoums verrou la news
et londinium dans chacune de ces villes
s'enchaînent massacres et destructions
il y aurait eu entre 70 et 80 mille
victimes chez les romains et leurs
alliés et cette fois les destructions de
ces trois villes sont bien avéré par les
sources archéologiques
finalement le gouverneur réagi et envoie
ses légions affronter body 4 quelque
part entre loudine you may fair ou là
nous sommes dans un lieu dont on n'est
pas sûr de la localisation mais qui
s'appelle wall street d'après tacite
c'est un massacre
l'armée de bouddhique avait complètement
détruite il y aurait eu 80 milles perte
de son côté contre 400 chez les romains
suite à cette bataille bouddhique hammer
on ne sait pas si c'est en avalant du
poison
en face à sa défaite ou de maladie peu
de choses sont donc avérés sur boudicca
on ne sait pas du tout à quoi elle
ressemblait ce que dion cassius la
décrit comme une rousse à la chevelure
flamboyante armé d'une lance et qui
terrifiait ses ennemis mais encore une
fois il n'a sûrement jamais vu de sa vie
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une révolte a
été mené en bretagne en 61 après
jésus-christ et qu'elle a probablement
été menée par une femme appelée
bouddhique
enfin baudis et rendons lui son nom
d'origine elle nous permet un aperçu des
relations entre les bretons et les
romains à une époque où la région
n'était pas encore très pacifier la paix
romaine n'est pas pour tout de suite
et en plus la légende autour de cette
révolte fait debout dit c'est
l'équivalent de notre vercingétorix
préférées elle représente la résistance
et connaît une fin tragique comme
vercingétorix
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu le
prochain sortira dans deux semaines on
fera une bonne avancée dans le temps à
cette occasion en attendant si vous
voulez vous replonger dans la bretagne
sous l'empiré romain vous pouvez revoir
ma vidéo sur le mur d'hadrien
je vous souhaite donc de bonnes vacances
et puisque prochain épisode sortira
après montbazon peut-être que je
croiserai certains d'entre vous avant en
vrai voilà à bientôt
[Musique]